hello everyone welcome back to the
clutch chest international we are
continuing with the match magnus carlsen
vs. Jeffrey's young and this is the last
game of the match and also the last game
we are going to show from the match then
we're continuing to some other matches
it's a very interesting as the title
suggests it is only in the details but
we're gonna get to that fairly soon
so without further ado let's check it
out Magnus with the white pieces opens
with E 4 and Jung goes for the Sicilian
defense we have c5 Knight to f3 East 6
and now c3 Magnus goes for the elephant'
variation we have Knight to f6
challenging the pawn here and now he 5
Magnus advances it we have Knight to d5
and Bishop to c4 so again attacking the
knight preparing to ruin a black's pawn
structure so nice the b6 now attacking
the bishop and Bishop to b3 and
sometimes we're gonna see a move like c4
Bishop to see to fall by d5 but here the
the main idea is d6 now which you just
challenged as a white c5 pawn prepares
to go Bishop e7 castle and so on so here
at Magnus goes d4 adds another defender
to the e5 pawn and now see characters on
d4 we have seek address and D captures
on e5 so a nice capture fest in the
center we have a knight captures on e5
and now not nice to see 6 with a double
attack on the d4 pawn also with ideas of
capturing here and let's say phone
captricity you can then trade queen so a
lot of ideas here Magnus wants to keep
the Queen's on the board so he goes for
a nightcap present c6 you could you
could also go back Knight to f3 defend
the d4 pawn this way but Magnus goes for
this we have captured some c6 b captures
and now he just castles so now he does
have an isolated deep on but chunk has
annihilated isolated sea and a pond and
also he still needs a at least who moves
the castle so Bishop to e7 she um
prepares the Castle kingside and Knight
to c3 magnus continues development we
have castles black black now also
castles to safety and Queen to f3 now
developing well attacking so here Magnus
is basically offering the d4 pawn for
this
sex porn which is fine for black nothing
wrong with that you know a more central
pawn is usually more valuable than a
less central pawn
however assume first goes for Bishop to
e6 he attacks Carlson's rook which means
that now Magnus will play rook to d1
also this will defend the pawn and now
Knight to d5 and it's an excellent
outpost for the night and I central d5
square also if you capture our black
we'll be very happy to under his pawns
and we'll just have an excellent game so
here after this the Knights the d5 we
have Knight to e4 by Magnus and also
forgot to mention here there is a game
where rook the C it was played but
Knight to d5 is a new move so already as
of move 14 we have a completely new game
so nicely for Magnus declines the trade
and also it will be a useful useful
square for the knight you can pretty
much do anything you want from there
even get it to c5 in the future if
needed so here now you could kick it
away with f5 but if f5 then you weaken
the e6 square also not something you
want to do so after Knight to e4 we have
Queen to b6 developing the Queen
connecting rooks and just just a nice
square for the Queen so here Queen to g3
Magnus is now preparing Bishop to h6
which will create some mating threats
towards the black King because you will
not be able to defend as the knight is
really here to gobble up the bishop and
then remove the defender of the g7 pawn
so she immediately goes Queen to b8 he
wants to trade Queens and Magnus says
okay we trade but if we wanna trade we
trade on g3 so Bishop to g5 challenges
black's bishop on e7 and here although
you could maybe trade right away trade
bishops here which is perfectly fine
machine goes for f6 instead he wants to
keep the bishops on the board and this
is a very sturdy structure so he's not
really worried about that so first
buster back to d2 and only now Queen
captures on g3 with H cactus on g3 and
now Bishop to d3 taking the opportunity
as the bishop is indeed you to put
pressure on the knight on e4 we have
Knight back the c3 by Magnus and now
rook F the CA to getting the work behind
the isolated C pawn at some point you
want to push c5 so we have rook a to c1
by Magnus he also brings his rook into
the game and king of seven now starting
to bring the King into the game to help
out with the defense of the pawns and
now Knight to a4 with the idea of
shifting the knight over to c5 it's an
excellent output for the night as a
black doesn't really have any beep on or
deep on to kick the night away
so if black wants to get rid of it he
will have to give up the disrepair so
Bishop to b5 are young even forces it
adds another defender to this d6 pawn
attacks the night and now Knight the c5
and now you don't have to capture the
knight but it is a it is a very annoying
piece for example puts pressure on e6
maybe rook to e1 will be an idea then
you might have some problems defending
this pawn so she um decides to capture
it Bishop captures and c5 into rook
captures leaving white with the
possibility of doubling up rooks and the
C file or if Knights to b6 which is what
happened in the game now you've opened
up this diagonal so the e6 pawn is a
little bit vulnerable so Magnus goes for
not rook to a-1 but rather rook to e1
and this is a very important detail or
one of the reasons why I've chosen this
game for example you want to play rook
to a 1 a 4 and start playing on the
Queen side however if you play rook to a
1 right away then Bishop to a 4 is is
good for black if you trade here
characters captures the c6 point is
nicely defended by the rook so instead
of going rook to a 1 right away if
Magnus first goes to rook to e1 now he
puts pressure on the e6 pawn and Sheung
needs the defendant so first rook to e8
and only now rook back to a1 and now
it's a little bit different because now
this a4 thrust is definitely a threat
and if you go back with rook the c8 then
it's like you've given why to move the
position is the same only the rook
magically appears on a1 and you can
already start with a 4 which will pose
some problems for black for example if
Bishop e6 you can go rook a to c1 put
pressure on the c6 bone then Bishop has
to defend it and then f4 let's say with
f5 trying to exploit this pin white
would have a
very nice game so instead of going back
with the ruction went rook the DA put
pressure on the d4 pawn but now Magnus
finally gets to execute his idea he
pushes a 4 now the bishop is under
attack and now there's a problem here
it's a very complicated position it
maybe appears like it's not but it is
because what happens if rook captures on
d4 characters bishop and captures Bishop
is black allowed to do this this is the
question for example if route capture
suddenly for eight captures and the rook
after sandy - yes you've won back your
pawn however be captures on c6 creates a
beautiful passed pawn for white and the
problem for black is you don't get to
capture the be to pawn that's the
problem if you capture the B to pawn you
are completely lost but it's very
interesting so feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out how
white wins here yeah well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the double double attack and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's rook to b5 and now there are too
many threats Bishop captures an e6 Czech
followed by rook captures here is a
threat and also rook captures here
followed by captures and then you pick
up the rook is the is another threat so
the way you avoid both of these threats
seemingly is Knight to d5 now there is
no Bishop captures and e6 and also rope
capture son b6 is gone but now you get
rook to b7 check King t8 and now the
very nice Bishop captures on d5 you pick
up a piece and you're just up a piece
because if rook captures on b7 pawn
captures rook to b8 now white even has
the option of playing rook captures on
a7 and you're still up a piece because
black simply cannot recapture if you
recapture then just look here wins the
game you either have to give up the rook
or capture the rook and then white gets
the Queen into the game so that's the
problem and that's why this a4 idea is
so super complicated so here she um
found a different trick he played Bishop
to c4 which seems like it's just giving
up a piece however it kind of isn't but
also is because here after Bishop to c4
Bishop captures on c4 and now she um
played rook captures on d4 now with a
double attack here on the bishop and
also on this Bishop on d2 but now again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for Magnus while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and picking either of
the two options and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show either
Bishop to a5 or just a 5 Magnus played a
5 but we are going to show Bishop day 5
as well as it's super cool
for example Bishop to a5 wins because
obviously now if you capture here on c4
then first you eliminate the defender of
the rook and c4 and now you're just up a
piece for example real captures Bishop
captures and you are up a whole Bishop
so what you could do after Bishop to a5
is actually gonna Knight captures on c4
which seems reasonable you pick up the
piece but now push it back to c3 and
that's the problem the rook has no
squares along the fourth-ranked that
keep defending the knight you have to
move the rule back and then why the just
wins apiece if you try rook to e4 then
f3 and all of the squares are take and
there's no there's no square here for
the rook as so again now you just lose
the rook so that's not possible
so after this route characters on d4
Bishop to a5 was a possibility but a5
does pretty much the same thing this is
what Magnus played now the point is if
Knight captures on c4 then Bishop c3 of
course wins the game on the spot as the
idea is the same you have to move the
rook and again white wins apiece
so after this a5 move young played rook
captures on c4 but now Magnus just
played a capture Sun b6 and it was in
this position that Jeffrey's Young
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here and this a capture
Sun b6 is the move you have to find if
you decided to play a 5 now now the
point is there's no way to continue this
your rook is under attack so what you
could do is let's say you capture the
rook rook captures on c5 but now rook
captures on a7 check wins the game as
you either lose the rook and again
you're up a piece or a black captures
and after characters
you
getting a queen into the game as the a v
square is off-limits since the bishop is
guarding that so the rule cannot help
prevent at the point from queening and
after this 8 characters and b6 there is
not much more you can done even if you
don't trade if you if you move the rook
stillbrook captures an a7 that it does
the exact same thing so it's not not a
possibility
so another win for Magnus and the match
ended 11 and a half the six and a half
in a course in favor and Carlson is the
one who goes to the semi-finals and the
will face some other players who have
also faced the same who have also
reached the semi-finals
so a really exciting game at least I
thought so I do hope you enjoyed it and
that little detail first rook to e1 and
then to a1 really was a game changer so
do hope you enjoyed that as well
I would like to thank the Neil Boyd is
Corey Tolliver a gunner Lipkin are
Superman Imani and Mike handle King for
your contribution to my channel thanks a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
I'm thankful for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the clutch
international chicken governor wonderful
suggestion and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day